[Música]
a pergunta que se faz hoje é pra onde
e foi a pergunta que eu já fiz várias
vezes na minha vida e que se insurgiu
três vezes para estar aqui hoje
a primeira vez foi quando eu perguntei
para onde ea nossa sociedade
estas manchetes são verdadeiras são de
jornais é variar de cumprir o tempo
entre 2000 e 2008
são notícias horríveis como já tiveram
oportunidade de ler e são a algo que é
verdadeiro e ao clube deixou a pensar
como é que nós chegamos ao ponto que a
gente não precisa contenção como é que
nós principalmente a última que um show
com carinho com o mercado de moda em
casa e não damos com tanto nosso vizinho
morreu é algo que me deixa muito triste
foi o que deixou pensar durante algum
tempo
a segunda pergunta era pra onde a minha
comunidade
eu moro no bairro 25 de abril a quem
estudou eu pra quem não conhece é um
bairro que antes se chamava bairro
fundação salazar era um bairro que foi
tem tem mesmo tempo tem até antes do 25
de abril é um bairro de casas camarárias
que são casas que têm as rendas mais
baixas por pessoas credenciadas
mas também é um bairro muito é diferente
escolha dos bairros que vocês conhecem é
um bairro que nós conhecemos toda a
gente mas ele mesmo toda a gente
nós não dizemos o lá e botar da pena de
nós que iniciamos as vizinhas os prints
os namorados as tias filhas e sabemos
que é vizinha do 5º cage já no modo como
lembrou o tucano se encontrou há 63 dias
nós chegamos mesmo tudo temos as câmeras
de vigilância antigas que são as velhas
sentadas nos bancos
o importante é uma comunidade rica tinha
muito foi dito é uma comunidade muito
pobre é uma comunidade que tem alguns
conflitos entre vizinhos e que deixou
pensar que poderia acontecer
alguns fatores que o frio nas notícias
anteriores que aqui um dia podia dar
asneira pela falta de ligação entre
hoje porque apesar de se conhecerem e
vinhos dar um stud havia problemas que
eu acho que não tinham seus o vídeo
a terceira pergunta que um perguntado
para onde era pra onde eu tive de criar
em estudo com um bichinho o ativismo e
com a mão queira deixar consigo andar o
mundo
portanto pensando é que eu poderia ir
pra poder mudar o meu bairro e poder
mudar o mundo é engraçado que expôs a
três perguntas foi a mesma a cabo do
prédio número 16 e tem uma casa que tem
que estar disponível no bairro ficou
disponível é porque foi infantário e
depois foi outra associação
fui várias coisas e teor não foi nada e
agora ficou de nível e as minhas
vizinhas choveram não vieram chatear
eu sinto do guedinho com nica e verão
vão dizer olha capital disponível vai
japira que o pai gente e foi isso que eu
fiz eu fui pedir aquilo foi uma união
pergunta aí é qual é a função que tinham
para que os pós é e falaram num centro
comunitário eu tinha a cabeça foi de
2016 disse logo que sim
se perguntassem então achava que eu
conheci centro comunitário e iria
responder não eu tenho noção como acho
que todos aqui hoje tem mais muito mais
que isso não tenha uma uma um
conhecimento profundo sobre a questão
então fui procurar no google com toda
boa pessoa em 2018 e atingir seu pomposo
que o perfil foi esta o centro
comunitário eo leite com off por
vittorio da sua ação a família
comunidade sem perder de vista a
situação particular específica de cada
pessoa
primeiro achei que ia ter uma distinção
pronta uma definição da direcção geral
da acção social não está incorreta
quanto este que era fria que não era
algo que ouviu do elemento queria ouvir
então pesquisei exemplos e vi vários
centros comunitários e que faziam coisas
interessantes faziam é
é várias atividades com isso os mais
idosos é faziam brincadeiras com
crianças jogam crianças instituições
famílias estruturadas e todo o trabalho
que tem feito é de ser valorizado quanto
eu tive uma visão de algo que poderia
ser diferente e algo poderia ser é mais
vantajoso
então minha idéia era criar uma folha é
o encaminhamento da comunidade tivesse o
num idade agregado familiar carências
jobs saber faltas sobre o gosto pelo
animal na natureza e que isto irá
permitir a primeira parte do nome irá
identificar opções estão a idade
obrigados a caminhar e iraí perceber
quantas pessoas vivem que de casa
a cidade entre elas se a discrepância
chora não viverem com pessoas idosas se
a idosos a viverem sozinhos e suas
carências
ou seja é que temos que criar várias
coisas que irão ajudar a minha
comunidade das pessoas que o que eu vi
que moram sozinhas criar vários
workshops e atividade e coisas por que
façam face a essas pessoas chegam em
casa e convivam e que não fiquem em casa
numa opção ou em caso de pior se matam o
como ganhou outra situação triste do
gênero é exatamente cobrir as carências
porque ninguém vai querer saber ninguém
vai querer ouvir dizer que a vizinha do
lado passa fome quando nós temos uma
mesa cheia isso vai fazer com que nós
pensamos também criar invente de troca
de alimentos troca de artigos e fazer
com que eles querem assistir acabam nas
comunidades
o sóbis os saberes e as faltas saberão
fazer também permitir irão também fazer
é criar o workshop de trocas de saberes
os idosos e ensina os mais não tinham
visto em os idosos os idosos ensinam a
cozinheira posto é o crouch o cozinhar
os mas não vi esse no facebook é fazer
uma
11 11 uma página é o é urgente em si não
há várias coisas que os outros não sabem
essa troca de saberes também irá ver o
convívio ea ver também a proximidade
aquela proximidade de nós às vezes vemos
a acabar e que chegam até as faltas de
respeito que o sim que é isso que nós
temos feito ultimamente nosso mandí e
afastaram de cada vez mais nosso próximo
depois o gosto dos animais e natureza e
ser uma uma questão próprio do meu
bairro
porque nós temos vários animais infantis
e nós temos muitos gotti
então os gostos animais vai fazer com
que nós criamos uma clone cliente
páginas é 21 zoom e sites que não irá
que irá fazer com que os animais tenham
adotante e estamos também com esse
problema que os animais que infelizmente
para o monte é um problema de de saúde
pública não é que eu concordo a 100
pacientes quanto a comunidade mesmo se
nós temos ideias em frente e todas toda
a gente tem que respeitar a mim como eu
tenho que respeitar toda a gente o gosto
pela natureza exemplo é que esta porta
que o baixo é um descampado é um
descampado que vai dar um descampado em
norma poderemos usar para fazer hortas
ou ou comunitárias podemos em embu usar
com cantante com flores o que vai fazer
vamos voltar a participar que as
carências se alguém passar fome
nós podemos cultivar a nossa própria
comida e fazemos também de dar onde é
uma alimentação vegetariana a todos
igualmente dada comunidade
claro que achei que eu tive foi uma
ideia para o meu bairro
porque a questão que se colocou foi é do
meu bairro
com tudo isto é um projecto que tem em
comum como idéias e em tudo os postos em
todo o país para que agora não temos
este centro comunitário com isto dessa
aproximação e essa ligação entre estude
e que nós batemos mesmo de frente com o
problema que são as carências
quando tivemos o exemplo no meu bairro
outro não vai rolar é que isso
o outro no outro bairro acabou por ver
mais centros comunitários que vai fazer
com que nós depois já tendo uma
comunidade próxima
conseguimos criar comunidades próximas
entre os outros futuramente mais dois
pra cima mas dois prováveis e condenamos
por ela
portugal integra uma comunidade e nós
podemos fazer isso tem uma rede e red
bull e fazemos com que todo mundo seja
uma comunidade
eu sei que agora isso parece uma decisão
assim o cadinho utópica e todos a
pensarem país serão muito bom mas nunca
vida mas a verdade é que nós somos
humanos foi de estúdio e me manda mesma
da mesma maneira é só o setor de carne
osso e devemos nos aproximar cada vez
mais entre nós entre espécies e fazermos
cada vez mais a luta por nós mesmos e
pela nossa comunidade e criando assim
esta rede global
nós podemos ter é no sandro várias
coisas temos noção das carências e
podemos criar coisas muito interessantes
com viagens entre bairros viagens entre
cidade e pessoas que hoje não entre não
tem ninguém pra comer amanhã vão poder
comer na mesa com com esta ideia e vão
poder para comer e se comer no norte e
no algarve um sítio escolha nunca
pensaram ir porque incrível não há
pessoas que sem vida num avião coisa que
escolherá que suas hoje que já andaram
duas três vezes
e essas coisas podem se fazer com isso
comemorou próximo e ele tem uma idéia
surgiu porque primeiro porque eu acho
que aquela frase pensar o corpo pensar
um local pra agir mundial é o melhor não
dispensaram mudar o mundo não conseguiu
ajudar a nossa vizinha
não podemos pensar é em si eu tivesse no
brasil não estava no bolso na hora mas
depois não consegui por e não conseguiu
dar a minha vizinha que era um vinho de
cor de rosa
a verdade é que nós temos que pensar
sempre local para agir no mundial este
dia também surgiu porque eu vi esse
vídeo este vídeo é uma chama a maioria
das grandes
é uma campanha da cáritas e verdade é
que estamos fazendo um time que temos
uma dificuldade o ser humano tem a
brilhante idéia de porrada é que é bom e
confusão é que bloom e foi estar no meu
próximo é que a solução e isso acontece
até chegar ao caos neste caso até haver
uma colher porque dá e é isso que propõe
hoje e jogar na minha colher e dar a
todos vocês e dar à tarde no bairro e
dar a todos é criar apenas uma folha por
um professor e temos noção do deixe
ficar diz que essa pessoa passa a nível
é financeiro nível social a nível mental
e criar assim uma sociedade de cor de
vida uns aos outros por não cheiro
humano de ensino achamos que temos cá
pra fazer se nós temos de ter uma missão
da vida esse é ajudar o próximo
então quem é finalizar por dizer que não
estou sozinha comigo estão toda a gente
me do meu bairro social está toda a
gente os bairros sociais toda a gente
que passa fonte o agente que vivem em
condições desumanas
é mas também está a mudança o crio algo
melhor ou criar um centro comunitário
com que toda a gente possa aproximar é
em minha pergunta que os deixou hoje é
sempre comentário estilo que é para isso
que estou tarde
esses foram dança eu vou vocês vão bem
obrigado
[Aplausos]